aussi sombre soit la nuit aussi ténue
sur notre espoir est ni à 4h en dessous
la lumière succédera toujours à
l'obscurité
si tu continues comme ça tu finiras dans
la rue mais si tu t'entraînes si tu te
bats plus fort que les autres
alors tu gagneras
si tu tiens ça gagner tu peux le faire
loup mais il faut que tu y crois pas pas
ils croient maman ils croient j'y crois
louer un moment de souffrance et la
gloire pour la vie
on va mourir on va pas mourir
j'ai une bonne et une mauvaise nouvelle
qui est l'athlète olympique ne me
regarde pas cher mais ses repères c'est
votre louis qui vous parle je suis
interne et à tokyo dans un camp de
prisonniers
je peux pas dire ça ce que ça dit sur
l'amérique n'est pas vrai cet homme doit
apprendre le respect chaque prisonnier
va lui donner une leçon
je pensais que j'étais capable de tout
je me croyais meilleur que je ne suis
qui te dit que tu avais tard
sors de là je jure de te consacrer ma
vie
palais louis
tu sais gagner
relève pas celle là lâche tu es le
tiamat